Künftige Siedler auf dem Mars brauchen etwas
zu Essen - da führt kein Weg dran vorbei.
Doch der Boden des Roten Planeten ist extrem
lebensfeindlich: Pflanzen und Mikroorganismen
können hier unmöglich gedeihen.
Das ultraleichte Material namens “Aerogel”
könnte den den Pflanzenanbau auf dem Mars
aber dennoch möglich machen.
Das könnte wirklich die Lösung sein!
Künftige Siedler auf dem Mars brauchen etwas
zu Essen - da führt kein Weg dran vorbei.
Doch der Boden des Roten Planeten ist extrem
lebensfeindlich: Pflanzen und Mikroorganismen
können hier unmöglich gedeihen.
Das ultraleichte Material namens “Aerogel”
könnte den den Pflanzenanbau auf dem Mars
aber dennoch möglich machen.
Und das funktioniert nach einem einfachen
aber genialen Prinzip.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
herzlich willkommen!
Auch wenn der Rote Planet der Erde in gewissen
Dingen ähnelt, ist seine Oberfläche alles
andere als lebensfreundlich.
Wasser verdampft hier sofort - dafür ist
der geringe Luftdruck von nur rund sieben
Millibar verantwortlich.
Super gefährlich ist aber auch die schädliche
Ultraviolett- und Partikelstrahlung der Sonne.
Bedingt durch die sehr dünne Atmosphäre
erreicht sie die Marsoberfläche fast uneingeschränkt.
Die Folge: Im Boden des Roten Planeten entstehen
unheimlich aggressive Stoffe wie beispielsweise
Peroxide und Perchlorate.
Leben ist somit nicht möglich, denn die dafür
notwendigen organischen Verbindungen, werden
direkt durch diese aggressiven Stoffe zerstört.
Der Anbau von Pflanzen, der für eine Mars-Kolonisation
extrem wichtig wäre, gestaltet sich somit
als unmöglich.
Doch die NASA hat einen Plan, wie dieses Problem
gelöst werden könnte.
Eine entscheidende Rolle könnte dabei das
ultraleichte Material namens “Aerogel”
spielen.
Schon jetzt macht die NASA es sich zunutze
und zwar als Isolator bei den Mars-Rovern.
Unglaubliche 99 Prozent des Aerogels-Volumens
sind Luft, ansonsten besteht es aus einem
Silikat.
Das Material ist ein guter Isolator und ganz
besonders leicht.
Seine Dichte entspricht der Dichte von Glas
zu weniger als ein Tausendstel - und dennoch
handelt es sich um ein festes Material.
Und das Aerogel kann noch mehr: Das ultraviolette
Licht, also das UV-Licht wird blockiert; sichtbares
Licht dagegen wird von ihm hindurch gelassen.
Ein perfekter Baustoff also, um eine Art Gewächshaus
auf dem Mars zu errichten.
Das hat sich auch ein Forschungsteam von der
Harvard-Universität gedacht.
Durch die Umsetzung dieser Idee könnten künftige
Mars-Siedler also Pflanzen auf dem Roten Planeten
anbauen und später Ernten und Essen.
Dazu die NASA-Geologin Laura Kerber: “Die
Studie war als erster Test für die Möglichkeiten
eines Aerogels als Baumaterial für den Mars
gedacht”.
Das Experiment lieferte erfolgversprechende
Ergebnisse: Auf eine Oberfläche wurde eine
zwei Zentimeter dicke Schicht Aerogel aufgetragen
und mit einer Lampe beleuchtet.
Diese sollte das Sonnenlicht auf dem Roten
Planeten simulieren.
Die darunter liegende Oberfläche erwärmte
sich tatsächlich um 65 Grad Celsius.
Somit würde also bereits eine zwei bis drei
Zentimeter dicke Aerogel-Schicht auf dem Mars-Boden
nicht nur für einen guten Schutz vor der
schädlichen Strahlung sorgen.
Zudem würde das Material dazu führen, dass
die Temperatur unter der verdeckten Oberfläche
um rund 50 Grad Celsius ansteigt - dem Treibhauseffekt
sei Dank.
Da das Aerogel ja das sichtbare Licht fast
ungehindert durchlässt und die energiereiche
UV-Strahlung absorbiert, wird diese in Wärme
umgewandelt.
Wassereishaltiger Untergrund auf dem Mars
würde so aufgeheizt - was flüssiges Wasser
im Boden zur Folge hätte.
Diese wiederum würde mit den aggressiven
Stoffen reagieren - ebenso wie mit den Mineralien
im Boden.
Dies würde nicht nur Pflanzen, sondern auch
Mikroorganismen zugute kommen.
Falls dieser Plan aufgeht, wäre dies eine
absolute Erleichterung für künftige Mars-Siedler.
Und zudem eine deutlich einfachere Angelegenheit
als das viel-diskutierte Terraforming, über
das wir schon oft bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
berichtet haben.
Hier müsste ja die gesamte Marsatmosphäre
der Lufthülle der Erde angepasst werden.
Eine Idee, deren Umsetzbarkeit von vielen
Fachleute übrigens extrem bezweifelt wird.
Auf den Einsatz von Aerogel kam das NASA-Forschungsteams
übrigens durch die dunklen Flecken auf der
Marsoberfläche.
Dieses gefrorene Kohlendioxid ist nämlich
- genau wie das Aerogel - lichtdurchlässig,
sodass der Boden darunter durch das Sonnenlicht
erwärmt wird.
So sammelt sich hier gasförmiges Kohlendioxid,
das durch seine Ausdehnung letztendlich dazu
führt, dass das Eis platzt.
Gas wird frei und befördert dunklere Erde
an die Oberfläche.
Sehr cool, wie Ideen manchmal entstehen.
Leben wir bald auf dem Mars?
Anklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatson abonnieren.
Soper Kanal, den ich unbedingt empfehle.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!